ever since people have been lending
money to each other there's been one
fundamental problem what happens when
someone can't pay back their debts
can't pay back
what are you gonna do and before i
really jump into
what we do now in our modern society
let's get a couple of the
words out of the way that we're going to
use a lot and these are words that
you'll hear a lot in the context of debt
or in the context of loans so on one
side of the transaction you have the
debtor
and this is essentially the person that
borrowed the money
borrowed
money
and because they borrowed the money they
now owe money so you can either say they
borrow the money or that they owe money
they owe the money on the other side of
the transaction you have the creditor
creditor this is the entity or the
person that is owed the money or they
lent the money to the borrower so they
lend
the money
they lend the money so we have our words
out of the way but let's go back to our
fundamental question what happens when
the debtor can't pay the creditor back
the money that the creditors apparently
do
well you know if we go back through the
through through human history they've
come up with rent you know various
solutions to this to this problem we can
call it if you go back to ancient greece
ancient
greece they had a very simple solution
to it the debtor if the debtor can't pay
back their debts will then become a debt
slave to the creditor
so they became a debt slave
so if the creditor needs some gardening
done or would like uh his or her house
cleaned more regularly the debtor and
actually probably the debtor's family
would have then had to do whatever the
creditor wanted until they essentially
pay back their debt through their labor
so that's how greece handled it you know
it's it's kind of shocking to us now but
that was their solution you decided to
borrow money you can't pay any more this
is what you got to do
now if we if we fast forward a little
bit to maybe medieval europe and this is
you know this is even uh charles dickens
father was even uh caught into this into
this kind of a bind
but until kind of the early or mid 1800s
in europe and the united states you had
the notion of
debtors prison
debtors
prison
and frankly i you know
when i described this to you you'll find
that's even worse in my mind than being
a debt slave in debtors prison they
would throw you in jail
so they would throw you they would
imprison you and that's why it's called
debtors prison and you're not coming out
until your family pays off your debt
your family
or your maybe your friends if you have
good friends pays off your debt
off your debt and i mean you know just
thinking about why this is especially
horrible at least here you had your
chance to work off your debt
here if your family uh either you know
if
my situation right now you know if i get
thrown in prison will my 10 month old
son be able to pay off my debt no i'm
just going to rot in prison forever or
what if my family doesn't like me or
what if
i have no family or friends just for you
know i might have owed someone the
equivalent of now of a thousand bucks
and because of that i could serve a life
sentence in prison so you can imagine
that debtors prison could be could be
quite harsh and actually charles dickens
dad was in debtors prison so it's it's
uh it can kind of tell you a little bit
about why he writes the type of books
that he does but anyway this is the past
we are now a civilized society and
hopefully we have a better way of
dealing with the situation when a debtor
owes a creditor money
and that's the topic of this video
and so now what we do is something
called bankruptcy
and just so you know the first versions
of bankruptcy weren't that different
from debtor's prison there are actually
more to protect the creditor than to
protect the debtor but now we have
bankruptcy laws and for the most part
they're to prevent this type of
craziness or for someone to spend their
entire life on kind of this
wacky debt treadmill so let's talk a
little bit about bankruptcy and i'm
going to focus on bankruptcy as it is in
the united states so let me write down
bankruptcy in a new color
bankruptcy
it's going to have a
u.s focus and in general talk about
personal bankruptcy although a lot of
what i talk about on some level applies
to corporations as well and i've
actually made videos on that as well
so let's say i'm just overwhelmed with
debt i've i have you know a hundred
thousand dollars of credit card loans uh
i i
have a mortgage to pay i have a a car
lease that was a little bit over my head
what can i do so there's a couple of
options in the united states
you have chapter seven it seems very
complicated these are all different
literally chapters of the bankruptcy
code
so you have chapter
seven this is called a straight
bankruptcy
and this is literally you go i mean it's
not a a simple procedure but the gist of
it is you go to the bankruptcy courts
you say look i can't pay back my debts
and so what they're going to do is
they're going to take my assets and then
whatever whatever there is there they're
going to split it amongst
my creditors and then after all is said
and done i don't owe anyone anything
although i've lost a lot of my assets
some of them are exempt they let you
keep things that you need to live like
your your pots and pans and maybe one
television and maybe a suit so that you
can find a job
but if i have a bank account i probably
don't because i
got so deep into debt but if i have some
money if i have a a a nice a diamond
ring or or a rolex watch they're going
to take that from me and they're going
to the trustee the bankruptcy court is
going to take that from me sell it and
then give it to all my creditors but at
the end of the day after all is said and
done i'll actually be free of all of my
debt so you can you it's kind of a way
to break from this cycle of always owing
money and always just barely making it
or probably not making it at all so
that's a straight bankruptcy and you
might say well why doesn't everyone do
that who's you know under under a big
heavy load of debt well one there's a
lot of rules that make this easier not
so easy to do
but the other thing is it stays on your
credit report for 10 years
10 years
on credit report
so you've got to think to yourself am i
going to be better off over the next 10
years continuing to pay off my debt if i
can pay off my debt if i have any chance
i should probably do that so that i
don't ruin my credit for the next 10
years but if it's just a hopeless
situation i might as well do it and just
so you know this isn't a cure for
everything if you've got you know if
you're sitting on three hundred thousand
dollars of student loans
i say wow you know let me just that's
gonna take me more than ten years to pay
anyway let me just declare chapter 7
bankruptcy
it'll be unfortunate to find out that
student loans are not cannot be forgiven
in a chapter 7 bankruptcy and so there's
a whole set of types of
loans or i guess you could say types of
liabilities things you owe to other
people that cannot be forgiven certain
types of tax taxes student loans
child support those won't be forgiven so
this you know this will definitely apply
to things maybe like credit card loans
but this isn't just a very very simple
process so any of these things that i
talk about you definitely want to
consult an expert on your kind of
particular situation to get a little bit
more detail but this is just an overview
so that's chapter seven straight up
bankruptcy i i don't have what it takes
to keep servicing my debt i want a brand
new start
now the next one or the next one that
you're going to be most you're going to
hear the most about about in the context
of a personal bankruptcy is chapter 13.
chapter
13 this is often referred to as a
reorganization
re or
organization and here's the idea is look
i have a salary i have a job but i just
have more debt than isn't imaginable and
it might not be just because i've been
irresponsible maybe a a medical
emergency came up in the family or i had
some unknown expenses that just popped
up out of nowhere
and so here the situation is
look
mister creditors out there i really do
want to pay you back
but what you're asking for me to do
right now is just crazy if you if you
ask me to do that i'm just going to end
up in chapter 7 eventually so for both
my sake me as the me is the debtor both
for my sake and for your sake why don't
we come up with a plan so that i can
realistically so that i can
realistically pay you over the next
three to five years and that might
involve you saying hey instead of
instead of being owed fifty thousand you
now owe me forty thousand instead of the
interest on my credit card being twenty
percent per year let's change that to
ten percent a year so there'll be a
little bit of a negotiation you're going
to have to come up with a plan and then
once you come up with that plan i've got
to pay that over the next three to five
years
three to five years
now once again you might say hey that's
pretty good you know if i owe a hundred
thousand dollars in credit card debt and
you know and i kind of go to my
creditors and and make a you know and
and look like a genuine individual and
make a nice sob story they're gonna
lower my debt i'll be better off than if
i didn't do it but here again there's a
you know there's a penalty to doing it
and and once again it shows up on your
credit report
and so in general you're gonna they're
gonna come up with a plan for you to pay
back your creditors over three years and
then after that it's gonna show up on
your credit report for another seven
years
seven years
on
credit
on your credit report so in general from
the time you file until the time it
leaves your credit report's going to be
10 years just like just like chapter 7.
so in either of these situations these
aren't things that you want to just jump
into and think wow i found it easy out
from my debt these are very serious
things that will impact you for a you
know a reasonable chunk of of of
of your life so these aren't just simple
things to do but they are good to know
about just in case you do find yourself
a little bit uh over your head or a
little bit underwater or you know
someone who's in this situation at least
it is and out where they can feel that
look if i do this or that maybe over the
next either three years or ten years
depending on how you view it they can
get to a new start and just so you have
a sense of how often this occurs i
looked this up
a little bit earlier in the u.s in the
u.s and as you can imagine we're in the
middle of a recession now so bankruptcy
filings are kind of going through the
roof so let me write this down so this
is chapter 7
chapter
7 and here's chapter 13.
and if you're wondering what are all the
chapters in between there's a chapter 12
which is essentially chapter 13 for
farmers and fishermen they get a few
more benefits than than the rest of us
get just because we want to promote i
guess people who produce food and then
there's chapter 11 which is uh
essentially business reorganization it
can apply to some individuals who uh are
essentially kind of big shots who you
know their personal portfolios of assets
and liabilities look a lot like a a
business so for them chapter 11 will be
more appropriate than chapter 13 uh so
that those are kind of the two other
chapters but from a personal bankruptcy
point of view chapter seven and chapter
13 are what is what most people concern
themselves with now just to give you the
numbers of how often this is occurring
just you know if you find yourself in
this circumstance just so you know
you're not necessarily alone and also
just to see that they really are
increasing right now so 2007 2008
2009. so chapter 7 filings in the united
states in 2007 413
000 in 2008 went up to 560 thousand so
this is a more than a 25 percent
increase and then 2009
819 000 filings essentially double of
the the number of chapter seven filings
in 2007 and if you look at chapter 13
in 2007 we had 277
000 filings so for every two chapter
sevens it looks like there's about well
for every four there's about three of
these then we have 334
000 in 2008 and then
370 000 in 2009 so you can see that the
chapter seven ones are i mean they're
both increasing really fast but chapter
seven is even more dramatic and you can
imagine because uh in a situation where
people don't have jobs chapter 13 really
isn't that viable of an option they
really have to do something like chapter
seven anyway hopefully you found that
useful and you know a little bit about
bankruptcy now